Blockchain and AI
are coming together,
industries are merging.
Where do you see
as being the bottlenecks?
It's all about verified data.
AI is in
very sandboxed environments.
You go to ChatGPT.com
and nothing really leaves there.
Recently we've seen things
like OpenCloth, where AI
sort of interacts outside
of these sandbox environments.
Things start going wrong.
People start attacking
your specific agent.
The question we start
asking is, how can we
verify where this data
was trained on?
Because there is now
a very real incentive
to start sending bad data
to, let's say,
your competitors, or to
other nation states,
and try to influence
the decisions that
their AI makes.